we all know the feeling of trying to get
through the work we have to do to get to
the work we want to do and that's where
Watson X orchestrate comes in whatson X
orchestrate helps you get more done by
bringing tools and data together to
streamline tasks like never before
orchestrate is an extension of you that
takes on different jobs in the
background while you handle the
important stuff work that used to take
hours now takes minutes simply assign
orchestrate the tasks you want it to
tackle like sending emails scheduling
meetings or interviews and Expediting
requests and it'll do the rest and it
will work seamlessly across the apps and
tools you already use like Outlook
LinkedIn sap success factors and more
plus the more you work together the
smarter it becomes and the more
personalized your experience
gets best of all it gives you the
freedom to focus on the work that truly
matters to you and your
business it's time to leave the busy
work behind welcome to Watson X
[Music]
orchestrate